[Music]
[Applause]
good to see you guys yes what's the menu
danny
uh it is um seared beef fish with uh
tomato salsa
and bread fish uh sorry uh what's called
brill
brill fish
meet tonight's brigade mcfly
heading the lineup of this band of
brothers is keen home cook tom
he'll be cooking with pizza lover harry
and dougie the weakest cook in the group
joining them in the kitchen is danny the
joker of the pack
let's see how funny he finds being in my
kitchen
tonight there's no support act these
boys will have to crank it up in the
kitchen
if they're to get out a three-course
dinner for 50 diners
time for starter a sid b salad with
pickled ginger this is a very um
lean uh lightly marbled uh piece of beef
it's quite sweet and the herbs
help to counteract that so it's a really
nice combination a crushed coriander
salt pepper roll that round the
coriander and cumin
really nice combinations quite a strong
sort of bitter flavor
the reason why we um sear these off in
the pan is to reduce the heat
in the spices okay i said be very
careful yeah 30 seconds
as i tilt the pan it's just sort of
rolling around sesame seeds at the end
into the seeds and again let the tongs
do all the work
be sits there vinaigrette soy
okay rice wine vinegar nice
peanut oils come out what odd of that
goes in is it doesn't matter because
we're gonna mix it up
this is a pickled ginger it's a really
nice way of cutting transitions to the
beef and give it a nice
vibrant kick okay cress is very light
and dainty
yeah lightly dressed and just
just spread these out nice big slices of
beef
we put the base on the bottom to give it
a little bit of height mixed up the
vinaigrette and then look bang
just over okay so it's three little
crucial
steps do i have a little taste just dope
i'm so nice yeah did you like it yeah
awesome yeah right tom and danny you're
gonna work over there hey
yeah harry and dougie yeah you're uh on
here have all you guys got girlfriends
yes so who's gonna lose the virginity
first
right mcfly yes are we ready yes yeah
now this is no rehearsal this is it okay
on order four covers table ten mcfly
four beat four brill four pancakes
yes chef yes is that what happens uh
when you're on stage and what starts and
three of you dribble behind
like guys harry seriously yes yes yes
yes that's better off we go right on all
the four killers table six four v
four brill four pancakes yes
yes good justice is on there right salad
where is it danny let's go yeah yeah
taste back in water who's dressing the
salad yeah
good into the plate and just push around
almost like you're making a little nest
yep there they go down and then from
there round
yeah okay good all right guys would you
play for that
yes yeah good table six please salad
back in the fridge
and doug yeah four more way now quickly
in a couple of months time we'll be
eating janet's veal i'm in charge of the
cooking
and the drinks i'm looking for the
perfect drink to serve with the veal
that janet's rearing for the f word
restaurant
rather than wine i'm going for a drink
that's come back into fashion in a big
way
beer and i want to brew my own
but first i've got to taste a variety of
beers to work out which flavors
complement the delicate taste
of janet's veal i've come to the
marquess tavern in north london to meet
will beckett
an expert in matching gourmet beers with
food
well how are you good thanks gordon good
to see you can you
beer is the new wine that's [ __ ]
come on huh no no absolutely not doesn't
know he doesn't have to replace wine but
uh
beer's got the whole range of flavor
that that wine can do and it's just as
good with food
[Music]
i'm going to cook some veal so i can get
the best possible match
little sprig of rosemary a little touch
of garlic
finding the right beer to drink with
veal is going to be tough
anything too strong or too bitter will
overwhelm the delicate flavors of the
meat
i need something smooth not too gassy
and something which doesn't have a
strong aftertaste
and there's yours there we are thank you
very much excellent right here we go
a little taste of veal right
it's delicate it's tasty so i'm looking
for something
that can combine those flavors
classic british beer madonna's favorite
but she's a bloke anyway
oh that's not right for you this is one
of my favorite beers
really really nice quite malty flavour
color wise looks nice
smells quite sweet see initially
it's nice creamy light but then there's
an aftertaste
uh it's a stout so it's uh it's cheers
that was one of the ones i thought you'd
like i've got some ones that i don't
think you like
try this one
see that's not too bad it's got quite a
strong aftertaste trying to eat food
with that level of bitterness at the
back of your mouth as well
it's a scottish beer aged in oak barrels
[Applause]
you're gonna get kind of vanilla and
caramel on the nose you get that bit
more sweetness
you can smell the caramel on that that
there's no aftertaste there's no
bitterness
honestly i mean how hard is that gonna
be to replicate that the the key to this
kind of beer is the aging process you
need to find those those kind of barrels
that is delicious it is i honestly
didn't think we'd ever find that you
know that we've done it
cheers huh uh dougie i don't want that
sweat
pissing on my beef okay [ __ ] you now
look at that do you sweat on stage like
this
oh i sweat like this seriously yeah
jesus christ doug you keep your pan
yeah in the middle of the stove you're
not going to get any cup there okay
okay so um we want um all right come on
how do i do it so my fingers don't burn
when i go near it okay now hold that
away from there
yeah and then like that just more in the
pan whilst i'm concerned you're getting
uh hot and bothered and sweaty
yeah keep the [ __ ] pan in the middle
of the stove let's go
thank you tom and danny yeah the chef
that's good yeah keep it up dougie yes
i need to speed up a little bit yes
danny
very nice
harry can you stop eating please it
looks so bad in front of the customers
yeah
when they're standing there [ __ ] look
at me at you and you're eating they're
not they get pissed off here
take it seriously check which five yes
hey well done yes
i didn't think we're gonna get there you
know that yeah harry is eating more than
the customers well i'm hoping of course
that all 50 want to pay for the [ __ ]
starters
yeah stay down yeah we're gonna sign up
for the next course yes
delicious i'm sure they agree a lot
better than the plate of lentils right
absolutely yeah empty plates everywhere
it's always a good sign
the beef was really good it was really
complimented by the sesame seeds and all
the flavors and the oils lovely
really nice out
what you think you're sweating in 35
dishes okay
let's find out damn
the number of people paying for the
starter it's 49 out of 50.
[Applause]
who was that where is she who was it
where is she
stand up one in division say that again
salads are sloppy what can i say and
what about the beef
the beef was the beef was nicely cooked
but there was too much dressing over
everything are you related to janet
street porsche
next on the menu in my mission to get
the nation eating healthily
i tackle a man who wants to run a
marathon but is more interested in
eating snickers have you ever seen the
movie run fat boy
the brigade maker meal of the main
you're course and i get ready to roll
out my home brew
for the f-word restaurant hold on a
minute
that's not nice and sweet yeah
right welcome back to the f word time
for the main course herb crusty grill
in shallots tomato
[Music]
herb crusted fillets of cornish brill
this is a very sweet delicate fish
packed with flavor but very robust in
texture
salt pepper
olive oil hot pan
we want to color the fish not boil it
one minute each side
take it out of the pan onto a tray
and now we're going to make a really
quick tomato basil salsa
tomatoes shallots
you can hear the tomatoes roasting in
the flavour of the fish
basil
[Music]
cool and now for the exciting part
bread parsley
parmesan it helps stick the crust
together and more importantly gives a
really nice
color blitz
that smells like provence beautiful
salsa be quite generous
on top of the grill really pack the
breadcrumbs on there
bake six minutes
[Music]
that is beautiful
[Applause]
olive oil balsamic vinegar
basil herb crusted philips a brill with
tomato salsa
done
right all tonight's recipes on the
website so log on and get in the kitchen
oh [ __ ] put the pen down can you give me
that [ __ ] you know
sorry let's go guys
oh we're gonna be all night right tom
in the early days jess when you all used
to live together and have been one big
house who's done the cooking then
uh pizza go go who lived up vincent for
about
somebody
no leave them over it's always best to
have one extra
clean
hey [ __ ] slow but nice go one two
three four
five six tables to go yeah come on tom
you're taking this out yes table nine
very very nice yeah the lady didn't want
to play for the starter
ready no that's fine that's fine go
please yeah
yeah yep good should we out come on
let's go
clear down down guys i've got four
trainers left yes
there you go personally delivering your
own i hope you like it
we didn't spit in it
health eating is a marathon not a sprint
the london marathon is the moment when a
nation of couch potatoes
finally gets off his ass and tries to
run off the flab
it's a grueling run and to have any hope
of finishing a good healthy diet is
crucial
preparing for the marathon is bloody
hard work i should know i've done eight
myself
i've come to south london to help a guy
who's been training for the marathon but
not lost any weight
[Music]
in the mornings i'd have a bacon and egg
sandwich during the day i'm snacking at
chocolates and things like that
i love thai takeaways they're my
favorite lovely thank you very much
my friends have been taking a piss out
of me quite heavily for doing the
marathon
so i really would like some tips from
gordon with only two weeks to go
you should be in bloody good shape
morning ben
how you feeling yeah good two weeks to
go indeed ready yep
you're not ready first one yes indeed
always the hardest i trust you've been
eating well
um not as well as i should be you've
obviously shed some weight since you've
started training
not much ready none you're doing all
this training yeah and you haven't lost
weight
that's basically down to your diet
you're [ __ ] i'm pretty much [ __ ] yet
but positive mental attitude i'll get
through absolutely yeah i'm not going to
quit yeah there is a big advantage
there must be 72 takeaways along the way
yeah especially through isle of dogs
yeah probably yes let's go have you ever
seen the movie run fat boy run
come on
i did uh two hours before yeah i was
[ __ ] literally breathing out my
[ __ ] ring i'm determined to show ben
that healthy food
can still be delicious it might even get
him to the finish line
come on ben jesus how he's going to pull
someone off
right i know you like curries yeah
they're a big advocate of courage yes
but did you realize down your street
is this beautiful little market here oh
thai market yes
okay there's no reason you shouldn't be
able to enjoy your favorite food
asparagus you know literally 30 seconds
in the pan very healthy as well cook it
yourself
rather than get it from a takeaway
you'll know what's in it and
can make sure it's healthy as well as
tasty some really nice basil
a cup of carrots p aubergines they are
absolutely delicious i've never seen
them before
a combination between the slight
bitterness of the aubergine but the
texture of a pea
here's a really nice way of making rice
a little bit more exciting
vibrant we'll steam it with some
styronesis excellent
right i recognize this man's face you're
gonna be seeing him a lot more yes
hopefully so
thank you very much i didn't how long
did it no quicker than getting a
takeaway
i'm here to show ben that he can enjoy
his favorite foods but with less than
half the calories
this delicious yeah thai style
stir-fry okay yeah 400 calories okay max
cut the vegetables
that's half the calories found in a
takeaway equivalent
and it's packed with all the slow
release energy ben's body needs
and it won't pile on the pounds cooking
the rice
water rice is a great source of
carbohydrates which give energy
[Music]
add the star anise and thai sweet basil
to the rice
okay with the beef fillet of beef
delicious and lean with virtually no fat
it's also packed with protein you can't
get hold of beef
chicken the same way is fantastic walks
nice and hot
the secret of stir-fry is having the veg
slightly crunchy
beef in and where do you study uni uh
cardio
what do you read sports science
brilliant sports science
ben healthy sports science
beef out mix the vegetables and the beef
okay oyster sauce rice wine video one
tablespoon
soy sauce nice
okay so we've got all those juices from
the vegetables and the meat
vegetables beef in
[Music]
that smells amazing
brilliant really really good two weeks
of this yeah these things
yeah yeah will be gone this thai stir
fry will help ben with these man boobs
and it's so delicious his flatmates will
love it too
how are we good good yeah great stuff
good thank you tasting if i come across
you
on the marathon i'm [ __ ] okay yeah
i want to wish you always gonna put a
spurting at the beginning yeah well put
a spurt in the beginning trust me by
time you get to cut it out you'll be
[ __ ]
if you're too slow i'll catch you up
we'll see you guys
the big day arrives i'm fueled by my
healthy food ben's raring to go
i certainly feel i'm more prepared now
than i was a few weeks ago i've changed
my diet and i've also been training a
bit more
[Applause]
there he is a pretty good runner gordon
he's run some pretty quick times over
the marathon
i wonder if he's getting his diet quite
right
[Applause]
ben safely passed a 20-mile mark a
killer milestone for even the most
experienced marathon runner
and congratulations to gordon ramsay
he's finally crossing the finish line
and around about three hours 45. not my
best time
but an amazing buzz as always healthy
food doesn't be boring food but
i'm starving now i'll tell you ben comes
in at a commendable four hours and 54
minutes
good lad
[Applause]
changing the way i've been eating is a
big thing but also doing the marathon
has given me a good kick off so
hopefully i can be a lot healthier lose
a bit more weight maybe even do it next
year
maybe not doug
look for four bits of grill the same
size why
yeah fair on other people okay now
they cook evenly tom yeah get the six
fish in the pan
listen to me now otherwise you're gonna
go down yeah and harry we're falling
behind now yeah
i've asked for a five there's not even a
[ __ ] pan on uh i know i'm doing the
potatoes and i know that fish
together okay do the fish you do the
fish you do the fish no
a pan for the fish yeah put it on
all right all right
get them out then quick yeah come on
guys
yeah okay now watch out harry
i'm [ __ ] doing everything yeah you're
doing [ __ ] all right i don't know what
that is ridiculous i thought you were
watching
that [ __ ] it by the way
same [ __ ] different days i'm doing jose
what are you adding cold water on the
beansport tom
stop bang
[ __ ]
right back to beer
i've been searching for the perfect beer
to accompany janet's veal
for the f word restaurant i eventually
found a winner
a beer from scotland which i'm going to
use as the inspiration for my home brew
there's no aftertaste there's no
bitterness
expert dougal sharp has come down from
the highlands to show me how to brew it
in my back garden
uh the missy's gonna do it [ __ ] that
when she sees the size of this barrel
you know that she'll love it
she'll love it and how many looks a bit
like yeah
yeah right that's gone i'm very excited
about this i mean it looks like
something out of [ __ ] charlie the
chocolate factory
yeah professor both for safe don't worry
people think i'm brewing the kids or
something when they're naughty
this this is the key thing ninety
percent of the flavor of our beer
is from this barrel bourbon has been in
the barrel first
right uh and it takes out flavors that
you wouldn't want in beer smell that
they've got a little bit of citrusy
notes in there yeah that's amazing
sweet creamy very creamy and slightly
apricot-y
my brew will eventually rest in the
bowel for 30 days and it will take on
the smooth vanilla characters
of the oak and bourbon so we've got a
tank of water uh 80 80 degrees yep we're
gonna mix
that with these greens in this vessel
that's mashing
the first thing douglas instructs me to
do is add salt to the hot water
then add malt roasted barley and wheat
malt
incredible it's like a huge vat of
porridge
so we've got mash we just need to cover
it up leave it for an hour
cup of tea sounds good after an hour
we are left with a wart which is a sweet
water flavored by the grains
super sweet great that is incredible ah
that is absolutely an over
next we mix in the first batch of hops
which will add flavor
aroma and a touch of bitterness to
balance the sweetness of the malt
you have a smell there completely
unexpected smells incredible it's a bit
like a pinot grigio this one it's a bit
earthy yeah
it's got a little bit of citrus
character and it's your classic sort of
british hop this mixture balls for an
hour before we add some final hops for
flavor
jack arrives home just in time to give
us a hand do you play football today
rugby today drink any beer today
all of you both surely quack quack quack
[ __ ] yeah
hold on a minute that's not nice and
sweet yeah have a smell that one in
there
put your finger in there just see how
black it is but it gets burnt inside
[Music]
a little wall paint
right you ready to put these in in goes
the second batch of hops
it's a bit like adding herbs to food
it's like a witch's potion when you
stir it which is potion excuse me hey
this is your dad's very own beer
hobbs yeah yeah so does the thing be
just put in that's right
so do me a favor yeah pop it homework
now the final step is to pump the
mixture into the fermenter
where we add live yeast which turns the
sugars in the malt into alcohol
so six to eight days in this yeah we're
going to need to let it settle out a
little bit
and we'll transfer it to the oak and
then it's just all natural
six weeks from now it'll be ready to
drink
excellent should we bless the brew shall
we bless the brew how do you bless it up
north
that's what this [ __ ] works [ __ ] it
you've done it that's great
how are we nice to see you how's it go
we've never heard of it but it was
fantastic it was a loveliest fish i've
ever tasted actually
yeah the idea of the tomato salsa was
the sort of bacon effect a nice fresh
tomato fondue over the grill which acts
as a bit of a sauce but you can still
taste the fish which was nice
yeah oh without doubt i really really
enjoyed the main course actually i
particularly i mean you wouldn't have
thought
that like fish and mint and shallots
would all go together because they're
quite different flavors
i actually thought they combined really
well to make a really nice
um really nice dish okay jose
let's go how old do you think we did i'm
praying for
25 to 30. 25 to 30.
the results are
35 out of 50. not
bad yeah but not very good it's no
longer muck [ __ ] it's
mediocre yes it was uh tough to
concentrate obviously with the golden
shout out and stuff but
you kind of get used to it now i'm used
to it and relax now in the kitchen
atmosphere which is good
while one thing's cooking you've got to
be putting the other one on and it's
just
nuts but um hopefully we'll get it done
for the dessert
next on the menu has the mad cow finally
cracked
oh no it's disgusting scientists turn
comedian ben miller
struggles to get a reaction i think they
can nucleate the uh
they can nucleate your sponge oh [ __ ]
are you still here
and i find out who's the biggest tosser
in mcfly
[Applause]
right welcome back to the effort now
time for the recipe challenge and
tonight's competitor is comedian ben
miller
excited very excited
yeah i'm nervous what are you making
victoria's sponge oh the reason i chose
this clown is i thought it might be your
weak point
it is my weak point yeah i may be able
to this is an old family recipe that
actually came from
my wife's grandmother here's the good
news yeah all our blind tastes are from
the wi
yeah they're gonna love my old
old-fashioned sponge
right ben's making a traditional
victoria sponge which is a [ __ ] worry
um
i'm gonna do a swiss roll i'm gonna use
fresh vanilla seeds egg sugar
whisk them up fold in the flour bake it
roll it
line it with some jam a little bit of
creme de framboise
and then mash some fresh raspberries in
there and win
what's in there i've got all my stuff
you're such
i'm not leaving anything to charge as
well cause i thought you're gonna stitch
me up you're gonna give me some [ __ ]
equipment or something
as you can see quite lightweight
anodized very good at it
look at you yeah yeah am i everyone's
good enough for you no
i have been testing them is that your
that's my thermometer
honestly that's your thumbnail it was
five degrees out that's reading 150 this
is 155.
so preparation is everything you're
weighing your eggs now as well
look at you you're such a buffet you're
right i am a scientist
and i think this is also why i thought a
baking might be to my strength
whatever the weight of the eggs is i use
exactly the same weight of flour
caster sugar and butter so you're using
an essence
smell that fresh vanilla no i have used
i
have cooked with vanilla pods but i
think so why not well
i find them a little bit sticky and i
think they can nucleate the uh
they can nucleate your sponge you sound
like [ __ ] hester blumenthal
nucleate my sponge yeah exactly holy
crap nucleating
particles are um particles that um
cause anisotropy in a in a fluid so say
for example if you want to make a
crystal
oh [ __ ] oh
how much you've been practicing a couple
of evenings this week
just just um just working on this this
one recipe
you know how competitive i am yeah you
know that yes yeah i clearly hope you
seriously think my hand is shaking look
at this
extraordinary from a tally to comedian
struggling over a [ __ ] sponge
ben get a grip man i don't really want
to win man
my uh alex justin you're okay with that
yes yeah okay good
just regulation 240 volts 13 yeah
let's whisk away shall we yeah yeah
whole eggs in vanilla pod in there as
well
and sugar in i'm going to whisk it up
into a really nice light
creamy texture
now creaming up the butter and the
caster sugar
i want to get it almost white so what
did you do before you got into comedy
i was a physicist oh no wonder you're so
meticulous to wear everything out
whether you read um at cambridge
and i stayed on i did a phd there as
well in fact recently there's a lot
happening in physics
because they're building this particle
accelerator in cern in switzerland about
this
it's an amazing experiment it's like 27
kilometer track that they fire particles
around
collide them into one another and
they're going to recreate the big bang
they're looking for something called the
higgs particle
which they also call the god particle
which they think now fans seriously if
you've got any jokes
[Applause]
i'm a chef you're still creaming
[ __ ] i'm going to cream some more it's
the fresh vanilla
causing you problems
uh right i've got mine into a really
nice thick sabion now okay
and that is light and aerated with a
villain running through i'm gonna fall
in the flour
and then i'm gonna be ready for the oven
i cream the butter and sugar together
then i add in my eggs
and uh the eggs have got the bit of
vanilla essence i'm using rather than
the uh
i think possibly nucleating you know the
pods i'm just folding in this flour
um trying to do his little mixing as
possible at this
last stage so ben's using uh classic
cake tins i'm using a tray because i'm
gonna
turn this into the most amazing swiss
roll let's go come out the oven i'm
gonna line it with jam
almonds crushed raspberries i'm good to
go are they are you good to go yeah
thank god for that
so both sponges are in the oven yes we
come back and then ben loses
[Laughter]
nice smooth paces something with no
lumps in there yeah
right time for desserts the souffle
pancakes with the rhubarb compote come
on tom put some [ __ ] muscle into it
[Music]
souffle pancakes with a rhubarb compote
first the pancake mix
flour egg yolks
sugar milk beets
and what we're looking for is a really
nice smooth textured pancake
and now our egg whites sugar
[Music]
whisk
mix the secret now just really
folding it in gently look that nice
smooth texture
compote rhubarb vanilla
ginger hot pan butter
sugar the sugar stops the rhubarb from
becoming really tart
lemon water
the pinkness of the skin has started to
really colour
into this really nice soft rhubarb
compound
simmer pancakes hot pan
butter
and flip
[Music]
icing sugar the most amazing delicious
pancake
souffle pancakes rhubarb compote done
component to heat up spoon in there put
wooden spoon in there so it doesn't burn
yeah
look right tom in all seriousness now is
it true
every time you go to swim pool you have
a piss in it
that is true tom for god's sake man
right roll it around
right back on he all sort of cries at
disney films by the way you're picking
on me
you cry disney films little mermaids
[Laughter]
nice flip it to the end flip flip flip
there
watch uh push away and round yeah nice
come on danny okay ready for the mix
yeah no
so that's the perfect amount hold it to
the edge there
yeah down and then around bang
yeah nice and sugar good boy come quick
come on guys come on harry i want this
to [ __ ] work yeah good go
please let's go that's enough
guys four tables of four one table of
six let's go
22 pancakes left come on guys come on
come on come on come on
oh [ __ ] careful double flip yeah no
[ __ ] out jesus christ of mighty uh
right off too much mix less mix in there
guys
not so much mix in the pans they cook
quicker danny yeah when we flip them
they don't piss everywhere
try try try go on try try go on
ready for a sauce yeah go on up come
back that's spot on
very good
how did you guys meet um i met tom
uh in manchester actually because tom
failed to get into busted you know that
you failed to get into busted yeah so
you join rook flight
enough talk about fate yes
yeah absolutely [ __ ] brilliant it
feels like we made about a thousand
i don't know we [ __ ] them oh 360.
come on come down let's do double
figures now yeah two fans on each tom
two fans on each let's go
come on doug keep it in the pan yes
excellent stop
that was hard here's the bird with a big
mouth
and janet street porter jamie and hugh
have been
banging on about free-range birds
and intensive farming but neither of
them have mentioned the healthiest bird
of
all ostrich it's healthy
and delicious but do people actually
want to eat it
no no no no no you normally just see
them in the zoos and you think they're
meant to be there
normal this tasty meat is a mystery to
us brits
what's it taste like is it like dick or
anything like that
there are 35 ostrich farms in the uk
but no supermarkets are selling their
meat i've come to kessie farm in the
scottish borders
to see if we're missing out on something
huge
hi walter hi johnny waltz has been
running the family farm for 10 years
supplying meat
online and to specialist butchers and
restaurants serving ostrich
all over the country why should i eat
ostrich on the health side it's low
cholesterol low fat ostriches healthier
meat
and out they'll come i've come as two
ostriches are joining the flock hello
[Music]
very elegant
is this affection
[Music]
they might look funny but ostrich is the
fastest bird on earth
they can reach 43 miles an hour they
really fly no
they can't they can run around and they
run in quite a bizarre manner
where they're next straight and their
body moves from side to side
sounds a bit like me running
everything's supersized oh my word
even their eggs with each one the
equivalent of 24
regular hens eggs waitrose that started
selling ostrich eggs
in 19 stores as a trial the shell on
them seems
incredibly hard it's very strong you
should be able to stand in it
all right if i stand on this egg and it
breaks
i don't want golden just call me a fat
old cow
walter are you sure can i have the other
one
standard right hold on
right hold on right okay you can step
away now
oh no it's disgusting
i can't wait to find out what these
weird birds taste like
now the next off it just looks like huge
turkey doesn't it
yes with 28 kilos of meat
these big birds could feed over 100
people for dinner
so this is the fillet um so why don't we
cut your steak and then you can try and
see what you think
okay walter's aussie wife die
is no stranger to ostrich and for once
she's shunning the barbie
in favor of a good old-fashioned british
hob ostrich is really good at taking on
fruit flavours we often just have it
with a bit of you know red wine
reduction or something like that
ostrich cooks twice as fast as chicken
lamb and beef
it's full of iron whilst being extremely
low in fat
so it won't give you a big behind i've
got to be careful not to overcook it
that's actually the golden rule with
ostrich
i want mine rare okay so you can see
it's just browning up
all right i don't want mine cooked
anymore okay well let's stick it on
tight
i only like straight rare i can't see
the point of turning it into a finger
so now i just took a bit of butter
popping your berries
nice blackberries or something like that
a nice bit of plonk
like that that's ready to go
it's nice and rare oh yeah that's my
rare steak
get stuck in wow it tastes great
it doesn't taste that gamey it's an
incredibly tender red meat with a subtle
flavor
i can't believe people aren't queuing up
to eat this delicious healthy meat
if only people tried ostrich they'd love
it so i've got a plan
right who's first the janet street pool
ostrich burger oh [ __ ] it's boiling
i bet you thought you'd never say those
words
tell me what you think you've got much
more meat in them than a regular
hamburger
oh look at the size of that absolutely
do you like it what does it taste like
it just tastes a bit like pork
it's coming from down the road all right
notice it's really nice
it's got a nutty nutty flavor i wouldn't
even go back and have another now
she wants the second one the queue's
enormous
the people of beric on tweed would
happily buy ostrich burgers if they
could get their hands on them
well my ostrich burgers have proved to
be a smash hit with the people of
berrycon tweed
they loved it
good to see you well yes you look great
now one more thing about this week what
is it
i'll stretch me it's fantastic meat it's
really high in iron
low in fat and low in cholesterol that's
incredibly tender
it looks fantastic it's free range
organic
and if you want to eat red meat that's a
brilliant alternative
when you went to josh's family did you
feel at home all those longer birds i
did not gordon no no but they're quite
fascinating characters aren't they
they're individuals but i've got nothing
in common with an australian thank you
but they're pretty gobby aren't they
they've got big mouths
only make sounds and they're shagging
trust you to know that that's a
fascinating
that is the largest edible egg i'd like
you to stand on it
oh come on i want to see if you're as
heavy as i think you are i know you're
always going on about your bloody nine
marathons
they tricked me into standing on this
edge i heard you stood on one
and it was impossible for anyone to
smash one but however
you managed come on so
here's here's the weird thing okay a 350
pound ostrich okay
okay you can sit on one without smashing
it along comes janet
at home with her ancestors and come on
have you seriously okay have you have
you honestly
put a few pounds on your old age ready
no i haven't right here we go 15 stone
oh no you're looking at my shoe
how could you do that hold on i tell you
what you just ruined my [ __ ] shoes
for god's sake woman
look your very own hard-boiled arthritic
with your very own soldiers look imagine
taking that to bed in the morning
look huh now have a little dunk
[Laughter]
i mean they are very rich aren't they
hmm now um i've heard that it's very
good for arthritis
the ostrich oil in terms of yoga i know
i haven't got arthritis
you're building up to one of your jokes
about my eyes the question is
leading to do you know what every week
you mentioned the fact
that i'm a pensioner people in britain
think i look [ __ ] great
you're a benchmark for a pensioner
really good to see you okay
see you next week david yes
thank you next on the menu will the
women's institute
help ben miller rise to the top in the
recipe challenge getting in a position
to nucleate mr miller
and mcfly find out what the diners made
of their pancakes
the amount of customers have agreed yeah
to pay
is
[Music]
[Applause]
right welcome back to the f word time
for the results of the recipe challenge
and ben miller is about to lose
i crushed my raspberries with some cream
fresh vanilla lined the sponge with a
little bit of
um flaked toasted almonds
and look at that who needs a [ __ ] tin
dealer
i must say very pleasing texture there
my son
we have a lock ah
[ __ ] it out look at that
[Music]
[Laughter]
however getting in a position to
nucleate mr miller
will you put in the middle of yours i'll
go for jam i've got a nice cream here
with a little bit of vanilla and a
little bit of sugar
dust mine with ice sugar
i like to do this little comparison that
ben yours does look
rather so delicious yeah fantastic too
josie off you go good luck yeah good
luck yeah it looks lovely fabulous
thank you come back with the good news
excellent
there's only one winner [ __ ] off
hello ladies the first place
yes you think hmm quite a surprise
little very pink right for my liking yes
there are some aftertones with that okay
can you do the squeeze tip
yeah that looks nice and soft yeah
nice cream um that's the one i'd
finished
excellent this is my favorite bit i
finally have one right jose let's go
give me the results now
did they enjoy them both obviously not
they did it was very close actually
very close very close yes come on
it was actually ben oh get out
oh [ __ ]
belgium little [ __ ] gremlin what do
you mean
what's your score four one oh oh
oh damian smith sisters what do they say
well they actually like the flavor of
the swiss roll yeah but
more the classicness of the cake
is in the [ __ ] oven four one
i've got a present for you i'm really
sorry but read that
please follow instructions carefully i
will unbelievable ben thank you so much
thank you yeah
promise you won't come back i can't feel
your back like a [ __ ] gas man
[Laughter]
you nucleating
was really good and the pancake was just
the right thickness and i think the weeb
was just at the right level of tightness
it wasn't too sweet and it went really
well with the ice cream
pancakes it's probably not something
i've normally ordered because i'm not
that keen on really about it i'd expect
it to be
a little bit stringy and maybe sale or
something like that but it was actually
really really nice really sweet
i really enjoyed my pancakes i thought
the pancake was nice and spongy
um and the tartness of the rhubarb went
really well with the sweetness of the
ice cream so it was a really good
combination
okay results for desserts yes how about
you that you've done
the dessert i think we did pretty good
yes let's go customers happy
very yes enjoy the desserts some of them
some of them have not i don't like the
sound off
okay the amount of customers have agreed
yeah to pay
is
oh damn
damn that is a big kick in the bollocks
31 out of 50.
what why we had the size of the pancake
too small too big too much food too much
they complain about the size of the
portions
for five pounds oh my god i'm not
impressed
right okay well that's like
disappointing yeah yeah
i thought we would on that so the total
for tonight is 115
out of 150. we wanted to win
yeah i know you wanted to start it was a
great start
yeah leave the f
with your heads up high yes right do you
want more favor yes
yeah i'm a [ __ ] off out of it get out of
here yeah well done
well done well done well done those eyes
you